think about it
i feel like a lot of the poker players
you know ten tend to be good at chess
and they and they tend to have uh
followings that really feel like they
can win and we know he plays aggressive
stuff but
i feel like sqc has has come so far as
we've seen from the first pog champs and
he is capable
of of upsetting anybody in the event
we'll see how he deals with this this
wild danish gambit from negronio
one two
three
four five he found the best move even if
he may not understand fully why it was
needed to not move the knight but push
d5 instead as a counter attack
d5 is universally a very good way to
strike back
because now black can just develop
naturally and and white doesn't have a
development lead so
so xqc played this and now he's captured
and
i don't think he's going to get in
trouble at all out of the opening
especially if he gets castled
but i do it does emphasize that right
now is kind of a critical moment for
negronio
okay and he does fine and he does cause
a king side this
this can get very dangerous for xqc he's
up material
but because of the f file and this
bishop pointing at f72
i i agree with you danny that if c6
um or even if even if he doesn't push c6
i think daniel will be
oh what a good move by executing well
this is
this is the best move everyone this
develops the bishop
and inadvertently attacks the attacks
the c4 bishop as well the knight is kind
of pinned
because the queen and bishop are ganging
up here this is a very tough spot for
white because
if white moves the knight he might lose
the bishop but if he doesn't
xqc can trade and eliminate the defender
of the e3 pawn so
look at how well he's playing right now
xqc is playing fantastic chess
what about my queen though pawn up wait
a minute
again this is tricky
this is tricky black does have a few
good options here but also
really bad ones because the position is
suddenly very
very concrete like how he touches the
queen so he can see all the squares
available one
do what he says
yes yes yes bang it move boom across
bing bang bang think about it
yeah now what i have here is a multiple
options
i can play this in many different ways
that all work
oh yeah now you sweat he's sweating he
doesn't like this at all
my biggest worry now as an xqc fan is on
the clock
it's true and time pressure has been
getting to him in
the previous match he played as well so
he certainly needs to
hurry up so that it will not ruin a game
where
he has been playing brilliant chess so
far he has found
the most critical most precise moves d5
was extremely difficult bishop to e6
just to
alleviate that pressure over the a2j
diagonal he's playing
the very best the very most the very
best the most critical moves
what was that see i'm just not seeing
stuff today
that happens you know that happens
i'm not going to take my queen he's
going to take
take f7 is under fire all right with
[Music]
i think so too and then the d6 bishop is
hanging and again the f5 the f7 pawn
and the king's safety so let's see if
first of all dania will take it
uh oh please queen h5
he didn't see that he could take the
bishop sometimes that happens that's
very strange
when a trait happens that you didn't see
coming like your immediate sort of
emotional response is
you know i'm losing i'm i'm i'm on my
heels right and and sometimes they just
miss that hey like you could just
capture back and i think that's the
psychological risk of being surprised
but wow what what
very short
you play and you pray
good motto from
daniel just resides big baby
he has resigned and we
do have excuses celebration what a game
this has been
grandmaster xqc he played almost every
single move
as the best move of the engine i feel
like when it came to that very
complex opening and then i mean
he has he has come so far and that is a
win
well deserved for xuc but he's gonna
have to do it again
uh in in the next game to really secure
that man talk about a bracket that's up
for grabs
right now right this group could be
anybody's anybody's win
we're gonna take a very quick break
before they play their second game don't
go anywhere
or pog champs three action and just a
few
so the second game has just started with
the sicilian defense
that's danielle's main opening against
e4
all right knight f6 played he's up a
minute and a half on the clock
and this is not the best spot for white
in a sicilian to have the queen
in front of your minor pieces she's much
more comfortable kind of from behind
here where where she can support on the
open files and diagonals so this is this
is a little bit awkward for
for xqc wait
bing bang
discovery
it's not a great idea here but it's a
great idea that he's seeing it
that's a thematic sacrifice in the
sicilian that i don't think he's aware
but he's looking at it as an
option very impressive that he spots
those ideas
yeah seriously let's go with our initial
plan here
original plan i think this is fine maybe
i'm wrong oh
yeah i think that's good so you're
double attacking my knight
is that gonna be a problem i don't think
so
i think this c file having that there i
think is
very valuable
up a pawn up a knight
[Music]
the danger through the d fight
excuse me takes the knight you take back
on e5 then there could be
a discovered attack toward the queen
bishop takes b5
first of all can we just get a moment of
silence for the fact that he used
booyakasha that has not been used since
1992. that's a that's a that's a
i mean boom goes the dynamite if we want
to talk cringe-worthy
terms then i'm i speak fluent
cringe-worthy terms boo yakka shot
can i get noted thank you all right
besides the bu yakasha yeah i don't
think he sees that if he takes here he's
losing to the discovered check
um and uh he's using the queen
at the same time there's so much
material uh
that's being given up that he will have
i think enough pieces for the queen but
yes this is very dangerous because of
bishop takes b5
oh my god and the rook is seeing the
queen let's go into xuc i think he sees
it
sacrifice he just did it into queen take
right oh my gosh
he doesn't realize he still has a lot of
material for the queen
he does have a rook and two bishops pair
of bishops and the rook so he just needs
to make sure he finishes development
places the king in safety uh i wonder if
xqc will spot queen takes b5 and it's on
the board
okay negron you has to see bishop c6 to
save the day
all right what are you doing now you're
taking my other bishop now
son of a all right
holy the problem is if he believes that
he made a mistake he will not
see the opportunity that it was still
okay bishop c6 was still
fine how about this
bang does that give me anywhere at all a
very strong move
i see it check oh
he did i see it
backwards take back first take it is
bang bang boom
sir sir
listen we're going to require you to
make a legal move here
come on
could you please make an available legal
move
the available legal move then let's take
got it i'm just shocked by the level of
play that xqc is showing in this match
um it was a very complex sicilian middle
game
and he saw all those tactics with the
discovered attack
toward the queen he's playing amazing
chess i mean honestly he's he's playing
fantastic chess
this group is has me completely
mind-boggled you know i thought negrondi
would be
the clear favorite after pokey's
performance today versus rubius and then
watching xqc
about to move to i think if he wins this
does he
guarantee he moves on to the
championship bracket because
he already beat rubius so if he beats
negron you
we might have a massive tie at the top
of this thing
that's the thing he doesn't guarantee it
because pokey can beat xqc and then the
three of them will have the same amount
of points
yeah it could be yeah and we'll look at
it we'll look at it and actually remind
everybody of what the tiebreaker is
because the team was actually already
they gave me some info already about who
has the best cap score which is the tie
break meaning who's playing the most
accurate chess
the chess.com game report gives you a
cap score so that'll be what decides if
indeed we have three people tied at the
top
but super hard for negron you to not
lose his cool there
but no xqc gets all the credit in the
world again like he
he's been looking at the at the tactics
you can see him highlighting it and
uh negron you did have a good position
but it fell apart and and
like i said unless we see a stalemate
here i think uh
i think we're we know what we know
what's about to happen so wow
i think excuse to learn the hard way
throughout the previous pog champs
editions about the danger of stalemate
and he will not stop it again
you'd think so but sometimes those who
get stalemated stalemate
others does that work i don't even know
well it doesn't matter because negron
you resign
yes easy
boys we're in it
next you see we got to start with you
this first game this danish gambit
you found this really critical idea of
d5
take us through did you know daniel was
going to play the danish gambit did he
surprise you and what were you thinking
when you
when you faced this opening and you
found this move d5
what is the danish gambit is it for game
one or game two
game one game one game one game so
my thought was only somebody that knows
they're doing it
would let me get two pawns first
spreading a third pawn right
so i thought i'm gonna do something that
isn't very good
just to throw them off because i knew
something was going on
it worked out because the thing you
thought wasn't very good ends up being
the best move d5 is actually a really
good idea for the future so don't give
it up and
uh daniel were you what were your
thoughts when he played d5 and
and uh how well he handled your danish
gambit
okay well first of all that's shocking
okay because the fact that he never
heard it
everyone i play with at like 11 50 1200
reigning
when they don't know the danish gambit
they never play d5 because that's
actually the one move that really kind
of
sort of destroys the whole plan so i
thought he i was like okay he doesn't
know the danish gambit we're going to
surprise him we're going to win easy
with white and he played it really
really well yeah and so none of my
none of the traps he fell into he just
avoided everything and then i was like
my brain wasn't working this morning
still wasn't working while i played
and before i knew it i moved my knight
into the wrong spot
um where i moved it to like an
aggressive position rather than like
revert back
yeah it was safer um because i had
another knight that was protecting that
uh h2 square that i just didn't think
about basically like you know
blunder a a knight or whatever so he had
me on the ropes on the first game i'm
like that's okay
we'll get him with the sicilian on the
next game no problem xqc
how early did you see this idea with the
bishop takes b5 check
or did did you get kind of did you kind
of get lucky and it fell into your lap
um it's a half and half i i i had the
root idea i had
another idea so i thought about um
if if bishop takes pawn takes queen
takes
then i have a cross over between a queen
takes rook and queen takes pawn
and then threatens rook right that's a
very good idea
yeah so that was the main idea but then
then i uh once i i started looking at
look at the peace move
i feel like when you see the piece move
and now you have the new board the new
picture
it's easier to make a new idea because
you don't have to you know uh
mentally make the image the image is
right there so then i thought
okay is there a check i could do to the
king
that would yeah exactly we're doing on
screening
yeah so now i was like okay is there a a
check
that that the queen can't do anything
about that that my name that my rook
takes queen
and then i've just found it so i was
pretty lucky from there but daniel
i know this didn't go the way you wanted
to today but this group is literally
turning into the closest group every
match matters and and your play overall
was still really accurate and good just
besides
those couple critical moments from each
game so i know you're frustrated but i
know that this group is still anyone's
taking and so
wishing you the best of luck in the next
match man yeah i think you got that
backwards because this group is pretty
much set
okay because it's already set like he's
getting through i'm getting through
there's no they were both through right
because i have two wins
oh wait no no because pokey pokey is
still has to play pokey can still win
oh but uh no no but no but but she's
going against me so no she can't
oh okay right so what i'm saying
she's gonna do great
[Music]
you